here in yorkshire we're fighting for
every vote and i know we've got to earn
every vote i'm really pleased that we've
got a brilliant set of candidates we've
got a positive message and we have been
laser-like in our focus on the cost of
living crisis because wherever you go
people come up particularly to me and
say look i can't pay my bills here and
i've been able to say we would have a
windfall tax on the oil and gas
companies in the north sea we'd use that
to help with uh energy bills so very
positive case but we've got to earn
every vote taking nothing for granted
want to hold what we've got and take
gains where we can turn into national
issues and questions will be asked
already this morning but obviously this
is for viewers who didn't see that and
voters who didn't see that either can
you confirm that durham police haven't
contacted you in recent days
no i've not had contact from durham
police and i think people are just about
fed up with the mudslinging that's going
on we know there's elections coming we
know what the conservatives are up to
what we need to do i think is to focus
on the issue in hand which is the cost
of living because as we go across the
region we go across the country talking
to people on their doorsteps everybody
is talking about the fact they can't pay
their bills and what's the prime
minister got to say about that he was
told yesterday about a pension who rides
the buses to keep warm and his response
was to say she should be happy that
she's got a bus pass and this morning we
had government ministers saying that
people should not buy branded value food
in order to deal with the cost of living
crisis talk about how to touch out of
ideas and out of excuses so tomorrow
really is a chance to send a message uh
to the government about their abject
failure and to vote for a labour party
that's on your side for the sake of
clarity though to the viewers and voters
can you say what you work you were doing
at 11 o'clock in durham and did you go
back to work after you visa
we were working we stopped we ate no
breach the rules no party um and i think
that's enough for the mud slinging from
the tories on this let's focus on the
issue in hand which is the cost of
living crisis
to which they've got absolutely no
answer we've got clear answers on that
the prime minister is suggesting that
pensioners should ride the buses to keep
warm and ministers are suggesting that
families should stop buying branded
value food i mean talk about out of
touch and out of ideas and out of
excuses britain deserves better than
this government i'll ask you just one
final question on this same topic i was
covered before how many people were in
that office with you that night as many
as 30 i had a team with me we were
working in the office
no breach of the rules no party
and you know this relentless focus or
mudslinging instead of the issue in hand
by the conservatives means that they've
got no answer to the real question that
so many people want answered which is
what are you going to do to help me with
my bills
we've got a clear answer to that which
is a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies in the north sea and use that
to help people pay their bills up to 600
pounds off their bills so uh you know
voting tomorrow tomorrow is the chance
to vote for a party the labour party
that's on your side and yet you won't
commit to reversing the increase in
national insurance why not we've been
very clear that that national insurance
tax should not be coming in to in when
people are struggling with their bills
and the government is
defending and protecting oil and gas
companies profits rather than helping
people with their bills to whack them
with more um tax now people have looked
at their pay slip last week thought i've
got less money coming in because the
government's taxing me harder and my
bill is going up and that's the failure
of this government so we wouldn't
introduce that tax it's the wrong tax at
the wrong time for whatever reason the
questions about your conduct in durham
continue do you worry that those
questions that as they continue are
distracting from your core message
what this mug slinging tells me is that
the conservatives have got no answer to
the central issue which is the cost of
living crisis if they had an answer to
that question they would give it and if
they spent as much time and energy and
focus on that issue
they'd be doing a service to millions of
people across the country who can't pay
their bills the government doesn't seem
to get this they're so out of touch and
out of ideas and frankly now out of
excuses britain deserves better vote for
a party that's on your side and that's
the labour party